allez encore une histoire par lo cor de
jeux vidéo pourri mais ça fait neuf ans
que j'en parle je me débrouille bamara
force non j'ai pas sommeil continue moi
tu fais chier [ __ ] j'ai dis tu j'ai
dit que fait chier voilà bon allez robin
des bois alors robin des bois
oui bon alors c'est un robin des bois
il était une fois en l'an mille deux
cent trente au pif on va dire dans le
grand royaume d'angleterre une contrée
de mes chiens mais sher wood c'est la
forêt la contrer ces nottingham écoute
j'ai pas écouter l'avis de quelqu'un qui
joue à forte night bref dans la contrée
de sherwood iv le terrible shérif de
nottingham
c'est moi le shérif le plus impitoyable
de l'ouest de l'angleterre
un shérif mais c'est pas au far west
elle est trop mignonne mais tu peux
fermer ta gueule s'te plaît
le shérif de nottingham était un être
cruel et démoniaque qui écrasait la
population avec des impôts trop élevés
[Musique]
didio un jour chéri vous verrez quelques
uns s'élèvera contre votre tyrannie
allait ressurgir un et renversera le
tyrol devra les sept boules de cristal
et restaurer les équilibres dans la
force
je suis robin des bois et je vais
restaurer les équilibres de quoi petit
sur robin des bois de son vrai nom
robin de locksley lui revenait des
croisades mais pendant son séjour là bas
il avait perdu son chapeau ou pour le
retrouver et renverser le ch et qu'il
avait rassemblé la fine fleur des
hors-la-loi de la forêt de sherwood
il y avait évidemment petitjean je ne
sais rien faire de spécial
mais il y avait également frère tuck
mais vous pouvez aussi m'appeler rabat
des mois et ange du coup parce qu'il y
avait besoin d'un soigneur dans le
groupe quand même et les consultations
sont ouvertes à ta gueule c'était pas
capable d'écouter une histoire sans
l'interrompre moi j'arrête et je
reviendrai comme sera calmée ça suffit
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut tout le monde est ce que vous
savez ce que les développeurs aiment
bien quand on parle de jeux vidéo sont
les légendes et les contes de fées est
une légende qui est bien pratique pour
un développeur c'est celle de robin des
bois
on a une légende suffisamment vague pour
faire à peu près ce qu'on veut avec
c'est assez vieux pour être libres de
droit c'est à dire que n'importe qui
peut faire un jeu sur robin des bois on
n'a pas besoin d'introduire les
personnages elle veut que tout le monde
les connaît vue qui a eu des tonnes
d'adaptation que ce soit en dessin animé
en dise n'est en série ou en film je
parle évidemment du film avec kevin
cosner de 91,3 du truc nul de 2010 on
est un gentil clairement identifiés
robin des bois on a un méchant avec le
shérif de nottingham
on est même une princesse à sauver avec
marianne et en plus il vole aux riches
pour donner aux pauvres alors que
demander de plus du coup vous attendez
quoi il vole aux riches
ça devrait être facile de faire un jeu
correct avec tout ça ne répondait pas et
on va commencer par le début avec robin
des bois a sorti sur atari 2600 en 1983
[Musique]
tu aimes le retro gaming tu aimes le
rétro viennois évidemment on va pas
s'attacher aux graphismes le jeu étant
sorti à 35 ans ça serait un peu
difficile de juger
on y dirige ce que je suppose être robin
des bois vu qu'il est le film sur la
tête et on doit tirer sur deux que je
suppose d'être le shérif de nottingham
et voilà je regrette pas les 40 euros
que j'ai mis là dedans pour acheter
cette cartouche on aura également droit
à un autre jeu sur atari xl qui est un
micro-ordinateur sorti en 1983 et on va
voir ça tout de suite
et
e
oui oui les jeux vidéo c'était quand
même mieux avant et ouais ouais ouais
[Musique]
bon alors après 25 minutes de chargement
j'adore le retro gaming enfin on peut
commencer donc ici c'est un peu plus
complet puisque maintenant vous dirigez
robin dans la mission est de sortir du
bar pour aller toucher la princesse et
et où vous voulez une bonne blague
après avoir touché la princesse ce qui
prend approximativement 4 secondes
ben le jeu bugs il se passe plus rien
lâcher c'est fini veuillez vous auriez
pu rien à 0
[Musique]
bref je vais passer sur les autres jeux
amiga et compagnie pour arriver
directement à ce qui nous intéresse à
savoir robin des bois sur nes pour la
première fois adapté du film robin des
bois de kevin cosner de 1991 alors ce
que vous voyez là est la version
européenne en cartouche mais
malheureusement c'est une version
allemande
même le livret il est en allemand der
calmes
ça veut dire combat je le sais
visiblement le jeu est sorti en espagne
aussi mais je retrouvé aucune trace
d'une version française du coup on se
contentera de la version américaine
le jeu commence donc comme dans le film
dans les prisons de jérusalem où vous
devrez attraper les paie pour vous
enfuir et robin des bois qui au passage
ressemble bizarrement un mélange entre
un des frères bogdanoff et david
hasselhoff bref donc on doit s'échapper
de la prison comme dans le film avec le
prisonnier anglais et azim le jeu est un
jeu d'aventuré en vue du tu es possède
un espèce de côté rpg 1 puisque vous et
les membres de votre groupe
posséder une fiche de personnage qui
rassemble vos caractéristiques
oh mon dieu cette image ne quittera plus
jamais votre esprit le jeu va alterner
entre différentes phases vue du dessus
pour la plupart du temps où vue de côté
pour les phases de duels alors ça c'est
toi qui es plusieurs gameplay mais déjà
la première chose à motiver fidèles avec
vota démoniaque et en plus ce [ __ ] la
hitbox dans les phases de duels sont
incompréhensibles regarder ça je suis
sur lui mon épée lui traverse la tête
littéralement à elle prend aucun dégât
évidemment robin des bois ne peut pas
baisser étape et en même temps il se
relève tout seul quand vous essayez non
vraiment autant j'apprécie l'idée de
cette partie autant je comprends pas à
quoi elle sert y'a pas de parade
possible il n'ya pas tes skis il n'y a
pas de gameplay spécifique à ces partis
enfin la seule strata faire c'est de lui
foncer dessus et de spa mais comme un
délit pour que sa vie avait expliqué que
la vôtre bref après la prison comme dans
le film vous barré par les égouts sauf
que contrairement au film où c'est
complètement éclipsé ici on a droit à un
niveau entier parce que tous les gamers
adore les niveaux des goûts c'est bien
connu
bref vous descendez discrètement par le
passage des robes et où il est censé y
avoir personne
évidemment vous allez affronter toute la
[ __ ] de ville où j'adore la logique
des jeux vidéo on le tour des gardes de
ce soir là vous de vous patrouiller la
ville les 500 autres avec moi dans les
égouts allait enfin bon heureusement
c'est pas extrêmement dure et d'ailleurs
vous ramasserez à l'occasion des pylônes
boulet ou d'autres trucs pour remonter
votre vie alors vous allez me dire
pourquoi je vous parle de ça ramasse et
items ou de la bouffe pour régine sa vie
c'est un truc banal dans un jeu vidéo
et bien c'est parce qu'ils ont réussi
exploit de rater un truc aussi simple on
est d'accord que la plupart des jeux en
général pour les trucs à ramasser yabou
fait c'est juste genre je veux un truc
je marche dessus et hop ça me guérit là
il faut s'arrêter ouvrir le menu appuyé
sur chercher trouver un objet revenir
dans le jeu relancer le menu ouvrir
l'inventaire sélectionné l'objet et le
faire glisser lentement dans votre
bouche il me dites pas que c'est parce
qu'il faut chercher les thèmes parce
qu'ils étaient cachés et je veux dire
regardez la potion jeunes là le ou joe
vopos et c'est ça avec tous les items si
vous voulez lire une lettre il va
falloir répéter tout ce processus sauf
que vous la faire glisser dans l'oeil et
c'est une [ __ ] est d'être un morceau de
poulet je passe quoi à part lire la
première est bouffé le second au héros
un effet inverse
bon bref alors une fois échappé de la
prison on arrive donc directement en
angleterre au milieu de la forêt où vous
rencontrerez rapidement chuck norris
mais non c'était en fait le cousin du
shérif de nottingham je sais pas
pourquoi tous les personnages qu'on en
compte dans ce jeu sont ou terrifiants
ou hors sujet mais je veux dire regardez
ça c'est frère tuck 2e manger 5
bref après l'avoir vaincu vous pourrez
retourner chez vous tout ça pour trouver
votre château rasé votre père crucifié
qui pend par ces boyaux sur le mur est
le seul survivant un vote resservant
dont les yeux ont été arrachés qui va
vous raconter tout ça
[Musique]
sont venus il enrichit ses tripes ils
les ont pendus aux chatons ils ont pété
dedans et en plus c'était son
anniversaire arrêté souplet niveau
difficulté bon c'est clairement pas le
plus dur qu'on ait vu mais en même temps
c'est difficile de faire plus dur que
cette infâme bodmer puante qui
s'appellera god terre d'oc
mais il ya quand même des passages bien
gras genre les moments où c'est une
erreur égale game over direct les gardes
qui hold up tout le temps parce que fuck
les règles et les ennemis qui sont
parfois juste stupidement rapide
du coup autant vous dire que ça rentre
direct dans la catégorie des jeux que
peu de gens auront la patience de finir
cela dit on va pas cracher dans la soupe
un niveau histoire vous l'avez vu le je
suis plutôt bien le film le passage chez
marianne l'échappée dans la forêt de
sherwood la rencontre avec petitjean qui
nous empêche de passer la rivière enfin
le ruisseau bref au final il faut
reconnaître que le jeu est plutôt
correct c'est très rare d'avoir des jeux
de cette profondeur sur nes avec des
gameplay différent est une notion de jeu
de rôle
quoi ça m'arrive d'être content si des
fois
enfin bref et la vraie question surtout
maintenant c'est va-t-on enfin avoir un
jeu qui suit simplement l'histoire du
film sans rajouter des passages à la con
qui n'ont rien à voir
[Musique]
aie aie aie c'est terrible mon cher jean
louis tout à fait en 6 tout à fait
minime en tête une tragédie sans nom à
quelques mètres de la ligne d'arrivée en
plus
oui enfin pour sachez que le jeu se
finit bien quand même vous tuez le
shérif et vous finissez par épouser
marianne vous pouvez mettre un coup de
boule
[Musique]
alors on va pas parler de la totalité
des jeux sur robin des bois
sachez qu'il existe aussi un autre jeu
sur nes intitulé super robin hood de la
plateforme tout à fait classique des
jeux sur consoles mobiles également il
existe même un jeu où vous contrôlez
frère tuck qui pendant qu robin des bois
et vit ses aventures avec le shérif de
nottingham et toutes ces conneries
lui il se bat contre lucifer et tirent
des boules de feu sur des squelettes et
ils ferment des [ __ ] de portails
démoniaque vers les enfers alors frère
tuck tu étais encore en train de manger
de te saouler dans un coin n'est ce pas
c'est vrai
[Musique]
mais je fais juste un tout petit aparté
pour vous montrer d'eux jeu que j'aime
beaucoup
déjà le premier c'est robin hood the
siege sueur ps le jeu commence donc par
une cinématique sur une charrette
vu de loin suivi d'une cinématique sur
une charrette vu de loin suivi de alors
ok des arbres suivi de tout en appelant
au bon bah écoute et tant pis pour la
cinématique voyant le jeu
des gens qui courent partout pourquoi
est ce que j'ai un arbre et un rocher
devant moi qui me cache mais je sais
c'est quoi ça sert
c'est l'art de bruit il est où le jeu
c'est ça le jeu ces sorties en quelle
année cette horreur en 95 et et tous les
niveaux sont pareils
ce que vous voyez là représentent
l'intégralité du jeu grillons et je vous
donne un petit sac avec non ça va
rajoute un petit doigt occupe tête parce
que je suis sûr que tout le monde
attendait la suite de ce jeu deux ans
plus tard nos voeux ont été exaucés avec
robin hood 2 the siege un jeu sorti en
2006 c'est à dire l'année suivante de la
sortie de la x360 la même année que la
sortie de la ps3 je pourrais aussi vous
dire qu'il est sorti la même année que
twilight princess ou call of duty 3
qu'il est sorti un an après shadow of
the colossus ou deux ans après wall of
warcraft est pourquoi je me fais chier
avec toutes ses dates parce que leur jeu
a vachement changé en deux ans
[Applaudissements]
sans changer le moteur graphique non
finalement je vais prendre un doigt dans
le cul ouais ouais ouais c'est bon t'es
calme et je peux reprendre alors les
attaques de robin des bois se multiplier
dans les bois de sherwood et le shérif
était au bout de sa patience ça suffit
on peut pas tolérer autant de
criminalité dans les bois de sherwood
il s'attaque le convoi un par un oui ils
ont même volé tout mon or des délicieux
bâtonnets de colin tout lors du
capitaine [ __ ] et bien dans ce cas là
nous allons les prendre à leur propre
jeu organisé - notre convoi et mettez-y
de dans toutes mes richesses
toutes les preuves que je veux usurpé le
32 bretagne une lettre d'aveux complets
un dessin de moi en train de tuer le roi
et quelques photos compromettantes de
moins en soirée au sud mais pourquoi
vous faites ça c'est super dangereux
évidemment mais ce que randa ne sais pas
ce qu'il va attaquer le mauvais qu'on
voit et celui là sera piégé ce que le
shérif ignorer c'est que marié à
espionner la conversation
moussan il faut que je revienne drogba
[Musique]
bah vous restez là bah oui mais on ne
prévient pas qu'il y ait un fondu au
noir merde
fitzgerald in
ben hatira robin que le convoi qu'ils
s'apprêtent à attaquer est un piège ne
traîne pas
[Musique]
tu me racontes pas la suite non ça
s'appelle au cliffhanger robin hood kwh
est sorti sur playstation 2 or pour
l'instant c'est l'écran titre et tout va
bien le chez moi mourir très bien bref
ce jeu est sorti en 2007 vous y dirigez
robin des bois qui part sauver la
princesse alors le texte petit bla bla
bla bla la quête de délivrer marianne
etc on connaît l'histoire de robin et je
vais pas m'emmerder à vous lire toute
l'histoire parce que le jeu lui-même il
en a rien à branler je veux dire dès que
le jeu commence le shérif la princesse
machin toutes ces conneries on s'en
branle vous êtes là pour livrer des
trucs mon bâton a disparu mais germe de
blé ont disparu mais l'irs a disparu mon
sucre a disparu le fun a disparu c'est
d'être une réédition du roman que j'ai
pas lu sa mutation mon nom et robin des
bois re signer à ce que j'ai connu et
évidemment chaque personnage se tient
bien au milieu du chemin ce qui
t'empêche d'avoir accès à la zone
suivante tant que tu ne leur a pas
apporté le beau dit m bref le jeu se
divise en plusieurs tableaux chacun est
entre fait de garder j'ai appuyé sur
absolument tous les boutons à essayer
toutes les combinaisons de touches
possible pour essayer de trouver un
moyen de les attaquer mais non tout ce
que robin peut faire visiblement c'est
de se recroqueviller misérablement par
terre comme un chat qui serait fait
gauler en train de chier en dehors de sa
litière
alors en regardant la boîte il apparaît
qu'un et qui est en voyage vous attend
pour l'instant je suis d'accord et vous
devez gagner sans votre arc quoi si tu
veux je suis robin des bois dans quel
univers qui lui enlève son arc
si je demande un enfant de dessiner
robin des bois il me fera un bonhomme
bâton avec un [ __ ] d'arc et si je peux
utiliser l'arc et pourquoi j'ai ça alors
merde
et pourquoi il ya des flèches tirées sur
la [ __ ] de jaquette du jeu mais ce que
ça sera en réalité ça sent le coup les
développeurs ils ont pas réussi à
programmer l'arc et du coup il y en a un
qui a lui dire où sera on n'a qu'à dire
qu'il a perdu son arc
m
alors c'est quoi le jeu ben c'est ça il
ya des coffres peu partout dans chaque
tableau certains coffres donne des clés
d'autres donnent de l'argent
les clés en bronze te permettent
d'ouvrir les coffres avec une serrure de
bronze qui te donneront une clé pour
ouvrir un autre coffre avec une serrure
d'argent qui te donnera une clé
permettant d'ouvrir un coffre avec une
serrure en or ce qui te donnera un objet
que veulent un déconneur du jeu ce qui
quand tu lui rapportera débloquera la
zone suivante et après on recommence
tout qu'offrent les coffres les coffres
mais ça va parfaitement car alors au
passage les pas dire mais le jeu peut se
jouer à deux joué seul avec robin des
bois ou avec un ami en incarnant robin
des bois et son célèbre compagnon will
scarlet qui alors c'est fou je pensais
qu'on pouvait pas faire pire mais l'idée
de génie de ce mode deux joueurs c'est
qu'ils ont mis la caméra qui est
contrôlé par les deux joueurs en même
temps
plus je n'ai absolument pas prévu pour
un mode deux joueurs c'est un truc
qu'ils ont rajouté au dernier moment du
coup la caméra ne gère pas tu vas ou ok
on va greffer n'ont jamais pas de retour
dont tout aussi sinon cela vers elle et
pourrait même en attendant je crois que
le cos qui les honore la teinte et
reviens à mes [ __ ] le caméraman il
est tombé dans les buissons encore mais
c'est quoi cette idée sortie du cul tu
vois que c'est pas terrible je l'avais
dit qu'est ce que c'est que cette
démarche soit 10 q
[Musique]
bref après avoir ramené toute la [ __ ]
de liste des courses aux habitantes
sharwood et figurez vous qu'on trouve
enfin un arc oui allez vas-y le je fais
moi rêver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tellement bougé envie de vomir et nous
voilà donc à la fin du jeu après une
durée de vie exceptionnelle d'environ le
jeu se termine lorsque vous ouvrez la
dernière porte qui vous permet d'aller
sauver marianne c'est bizarre j'ai
l'impression qu'on a oublié un truc mais
merde on a complètement vient de mettre
le cherche dans l'histoire va qui devait
s'en occuper
harb un ou deux me voilà enfin libéré de
l'emprise ce diabolique shérif
pourquoi as tu été aussi long j'ai
presque failli me libérer tout seul
allez on prend au coeur de la forêt de
cheyrou waouh travail au coeur de la
forêt de sherwood le convoi piégé du
shérif progresser et l'embuscade était
prête
il était temps de passer à l'action pour
robin ses amis
[Musique]
éperdu raté je veux dire halte là je
suis robin des bois et vous allez nous
livrer tout votre corps et vous remet un
des bois
[Rires]
[Musique]
haha tu es tombé dans un piège rôle un
piège mais comment mes robes en tulle
aperçu mon message par pigeon voyageur
aux mariannes on a déjà eu cette
discussion tu ne sais pas parler aux
animaux
ça suffit
[Musique]
finir assez déçu au plus tard
les petits gens attention derrière
histoire
[Musique]
m
on ne remet pas venu
[Musique]
bon c'est que techniquement c'est notre
ennemi et sur la taxe ne soit pas un peu
nous des antisémites dépêchez vous
bonsoir de confusion mentale ne va pas
durer très longtemps
[Musique]
je veux juste entre nous même dans chéri
ça me fait que commencer et romain
ménard des abords de la forêt des
centaines de chevalier montées sur des
pneus en armure déplaire et cherchèrent
les agglos heureusement ceux ci avaient
prévenu leurs alliés les centaures gi
avait emmené
se catapultent depuis les contrées du
wildfire verte aurait était en feu le
chaos était total rien plus d'image
[Musique]
c'est une et chérif votre quinquennat
terreur est terminé maintenant vous
allez faire des réformes
et c'est ainsi que robin des bois de 20
watts breton l'inventa l'ampoulé
électrique basse consommation et mourut
dans son sommeil paisiblement d'un
cancer foudroyant de moi
[Musique]
on
et voilà c'était l'histoire de robin des
bois
non mais attends c'était qui cette
gamine